- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is Impose Your Will.
Over to you, Inky Johnson.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso'll keep me goin'
♫ I wake up every mornin'♫
- You know why people quit?
People don't have pride in what they do.
You know why people stop?
They're selfish and it's just about them.
When you have a bigger
purpose to why you're doin'
what you're doin', and you
want to honor the sacrifices
that others have made
for you, it's nothin'
for you to keep goin'
when you hit adversity.
If every decision and choice
you make is just about you,
at certain point you're
going to hit somethin'
that's a lot tougher than you,
and it's going to make you quit
because you don't have a
drivin' force for why you do
what you do.
But when I got up to the
University of Tennessee,
it was simple.
It was simple for me to
give everything I had.
My freshman year, I played special teams.
My sophomore season I
broke the star lineup,
had a really strong sophomore season.
The summer headin' into my
junior year, I still remember
the day while I was
sittin' in that film room,
I was watchin' film on
the California Bears.
My Defensive Backs Coach,
Larry Slade, came in the room
he said, "Inky, I got
some good news for you."
I dropped the clicker,
I said, "What is it?"
He said, "Man, your projected
top 30 draft pick, son."
He said, "All you have to do is play
"the next 10 football games.
"You're an automatic multimillionaire."
I went out of that room.
I called my mother and my
grandmother on a three way.
I said, "After this season,
there'll be no more struggle."
I said, "We will never miss another meal."
I said, "We will never
experience another Christmas
"where we have to stand
on the side of the curb
"and just be grateful."
Now, I hung it up.
First football game, I
went out and played great.
Got an interception.
Shut Cal down.
Second game, we kind of get scared for us.
Got late in the game, fourth quarter.
Guy dropped back, he threw
the ball to a receiver
comin' out of my side line.
Me and the guy, we went head on.
Soon as I hit the guy, I
felt as if every breath
in my body left.
Body went completely limp.
Fell to the ground and I blacked out.
Never happened to me before.
When my eyes opened, I'll never forget.
My team mates ran over, they
said, "Ink, get up, let's go."
I said, "I can't."
I said, "I can't move."
They said, "What do you
mean you can't move?
"You're our lock down
quarter, man, we need you.
"Let's go."
I said, "I know man, but
this time I can't move."
I flipped my head up to
the sky and said, "God,"
I said, "Surely nothin'
has happened in this moment
"that can alter my life."
They got me over to the
hospital, they took me back,
they ran CAT scans, they
brought me back into my room
and all in a 15 second
time frame, the doctor came
runnin' from the opposite side.
He said, "Hey, get in here,
we got to rush this guy
"back to emergency surgery.
"He's about to die."
I said, "What?"
He said, "Son, you have
busted a subclavian artery
"in your chest.
"You're bleedin' internally.
"We have to rush you
back, take the main vein
"out of your left leg,
plug it into your chest
"in order to save your life."
When I opened my eyes from
recovery, the same doctor
was over me.
He said, "Son, have some good news
"and some bad news for ya."
I said, "You got some bad
news for me after tellin' me
"I'm about to die?
"I'm still alive.
"How bad can it get?
"I'm still here."
(audience giggles)
He said, "The good news
is we saved your life."
I said, "Thank you, sir."
He said, "The bad news is,
Ink, you have nerve damage
"in your right shoulder."
I said, "Okay, cool."
He said, "But son, it's
a strong possibility
"that you probably can never
play the game of football
"again in your life."
I said, "No way."
I said, "No disrespect to you,
doc, but I've been workin'
"for this ever since I
was seven years old."
I said, "No disrespect to you, doc,
"but you wasn't in the
park with me and my mother.
"And I was seven years old
and she was sittin' in that
"Buick re-got when she got
done working at Wendy's.
"No disrespect to you,
doc, but you didn't come up
"in that two bedroom home, 14 people,
"sleepin' on the floor.
"No disrespect to you,
doc, but you didn't miss
"those meals and stay focused
and never made an excuse."
I never cheated.
Like my conscience, still
until this day, won't let me,
like I can't cheat.
I can't look myself in the
mirror and say, "Ink, you did
"a good job" knowin' that I cheated.
I can't cheat.
One of the greatest pieces
of advice that my mother
gave me was this.
"Son, whatever you start,
you make sure you finish it."
And the problem with the world
today, people get involved
with things, and if they
don't like a certain person,
if they don't like the
process, if it's not what they
thought it was, they quit.
And what they don't
understand about quittin',
quittin' becomes a habit
that doesn't just affect you.
Later on in life, when you get
a wife and you get some kids,
when you get a family, it's
going to come back to haunt you.
And then will one day affect them.
That is why I tell you the
process is more important
than the product.
It's not even about the outcome for me.
It's about can you take
pride in what you do
as an individual?
And every night, when
you look in the mirror,
knowin' that you gave
everything that you had to it.
And we have to get to the
point where we're willing
to impose our will on certain things.
Impose your will on it.
My life totally changed, and
they gave me an opportunity
to stop.
And most people, when you give
them an opportunity to stop
while they're chasin' somethin',
they take advantage of it
because they feel like,
"Man, why did this have to
"happen to me?"
I felt as if, "Why not me?"
This is the perfect opportunity
to use this to be a blessing
to somebody else.
And you know what?
It's not even about me to be truthful.
It's not even about me.
Now it's about repayin' the
people that invested in me
and saw somethin' in me when
I couldn't see it in myself.
At a certain point in life,
it just can't be about you.
And the moment that we
understand that, and every day
we wake up, we understand
that life is a blessin'
and life is a gift.
And if you were to check out
today, how would you want
to be remembered?
It's bigger than you.
- So first off, this is an
amazingly powerful clip.
I had never heard of Inky
before doing the research
for this video.
So, whoever of you guys in
Believe Nation suggested
that we do him, I am grateful.
Thank you so much.
I'm expecting a power house of a top 10
coming on Inky.
My quick thoughts on this is,
I'm a big believer in the Army of One.
And that's where I will will
something into existence.
And so, when I'm starting
off a new project
that I'm passionate about, that
I want to see come to life,
that I have this idea
that maybe other people
think is crazy.
I'm going to will it into existence.
I am going to make it happen.
And at the start, I'll
involve people and say,
"Hey, do you want to join me?
"What do you think?
"Do you want to be a part of this?"
Try to build up a team
and if they come on board,
amazingly, we'll build
this thing together,
and if they don't, if they don't like it,
they don't see how they can fit,
they don't want to help out,
I will be an Army of One,
and will it into existence.
I will make it happen.
And as we get a little more
success, then I can afford
to hire somebody to come on and help me
if you won't want to join me
and partner up at the beginning.
That's okay.
You saying no, you tellin'
me how stupid somethin' is,
you tellin' me how it's not
going to work, does not impact
my willingness to go and do it.
And I think that's where
most people fall short.
You are living your life too
much from the expectations
and beliefs of other people.
Whether that's your family, your friends,
people around you, your parents, whoever.
Doctors.
You're livin' your life
according to the opinions
and beliefs of other people.
Instead of setting the
standard so high for yourself,
that it doesn't matter what
the people underneath think.
If you set your standards for up here,
and everybody else
expects you to play here,
then even when you fall short,
you're harder on yourself
than anybody else can be on you.
You know, if I'm late for
a meeting, that might upset
somebody, you know, that
person that that I'm meeting.
I'm way harder on myself than
they are ever going to be,
'cause I hate being late for a meeting.
There's a new potential
instructor I'm looking at
for my dance studio.
And, she really badly wants
to become an instructor.
And she's on her path and
she's learning and growing,
and developing the skills
to be able to do that.
And she goes home and she tells her family
"Hey I want to be an instructor here.
"I think I can make an impact."
And her sister, the first
thing that she tells her,
her sister tells her that she can't do it.
Her sister tells her that
she's not good enough,
that who is she that she
thinks she can be an instructor
and teach dance.
And for a lot of people,
that's the end, right.
For a lot of people, they give up.
They quit.
They're done.
Because your sister
thinks you can't do it,
therefore you think you
can't do it and so you stop.
And in life, along the path to any goal
that you're trying to
accomplish, you're going to hit
tons of road blocks.
Tons of road blocks.
The challenge is the
process of overcoming those.
And if you don't believe
in what you've got,
you're always going to be
subject to the opinions
of other people.
If you quit on your dance dream
because your sister says
you're not good enough,
then you're always just livin' up
to your sister's expectations
for what you can do.
As opposed to what you want to do.
And it sucks not to get
your sister's support,
or your parents' support, or
your best friend's support,
but it doesn't matter.
You don't need their support to be you.
You don't need their support to be
the greatest version of yourself.
You don't need their support to go
and build your dreams.
Their opinion of you
does not impact
your self confidence.
Does not have an impact
on your self worth.
If you guys love my
videos, that's amazing.
If you guys hate my videos, I don't care.
Can I take feedback on
how to make them better?
100%.
But if you don't like me, the way I talk,
the way I look, the what I'm doing,
doesn't matter to me.
If you're constantly living your life
by the opinions of other people,
you're never going to go
out and live your dreams.
And so it's great to involve people,
it's great to get expert opinions,
it's great to tell friends and family.
And if they're supportive
and understanding,
they can give you
resources, and knowledge,
and mentorship, and advice,
and guidance, amazing.
And if they can't,
if they're either apathetic
and they don't care
about it, or worse, they're negative
and just trash your idea,
doesn't matter.
You're going to will it into existance.
You're going to be an Army of One.
Because this is your dream.
And you can't blame anybody else for you
not chasing your dream.
If you don't go out and hit it,
it's not your sister's fault.
It's not your mom's fault.
It's not your best friend's fault.
It's your fault.
So, own it.
Be an Army of One and
will it into existence.
So the question of the day today is
I'm curious, what have you
had to will into existence?
Something that everybody
was told you was crazy,
would never work, you have no shot,
and you just made it happen.
I want to hear your story.
Share it, leave it down
in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kamiana Jardine.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
You're One Word.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso'll keep me goin' ♫